hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear my little movie review series
so how's this for a bizarre coincidence
so i had been sort of perusing the
movies that shutter had been adding all
throughout the last couple months like
june july that i hadn't got around to
watching yet
you know with a view to kind of like
putting them on the docket for my august
reviews or at least some of my august
reviews because i do kind of like to
keep up with the new content that they
post
and while i was looking through there i
happened upon this movie from 2010 and
it was called all about evil
i didn't really know all that much about
it uh but i read like the short synopsis
it's only like a sentence or two and
that actually sounded really fun
and it also had the coveted five skull
ratings among like shutter uh
subscribers who had watched it which you
don't really see a lot i mean if you
have a subscription to shutter i mean a
lot of good movies even like a really
good movie will usually just get four
because there'll be a couple in there
being logo this blah blah blah so it's
very very rare to see one with five
skulls but this one had five skulls and
that intrigued me so i'm like okay i'm
definitely gonna watch that one then
so i scheduled it for viewing
uh one saturday afternoon when i knew
that i wasn't gonna have any other
things going on
on the very morning of the day that i
was planning to watch it like before i
even watched it
i happened to be randomly reading this
article but it just which had just been
posted like a couple hours before i read
it and it was actually about the 30th
anniversary of one of my favorite movies
from the 1990s which is death becomes
her which is a fantastic dark comedy if
you haven't seen it with meryl streep
and goldie hawn and bruce willis
and so it was kind of about the 30th
anniversary of that and the movies sort
of the way that it's become kind of like
a touchstone of queer culture
now a large part of this article
was comprised of an interview
with a filmmaker and iconic san
francisco drag performer uh called
peaches christ aka joshua grinnell i
think is how you pronounce his last name
uh who it turns out also directed all
about evil i totally did not do that on
purpose i swear to god and i really
don't know how that happened
uh i don't know how i managed to like
that kind of kismet or like coincidental
whatever but there you go uh universe
was i guess clearly telling me to watch
and review this movie so who am i to
quibble with the universe they want me
to do it so i'm doing it so here you go
now apparently all about evil had a real
limited release like back in 2010
and then went into kind of like a limbo
for pretty much more than a decade i
think joshua grinnell like actually
released it privately or like released
it like self-published it type of thing
and it was like really really hard to
get hold of for like a really long time
now thankfully this travesty was
recently rectified by good old severan
films who actually released a special
edition blu-ray of it in 2022 and as i
mentioned shutter added it to their
platform in june of this year and good
for them i have to say because all about
evil is a blast it is so so fun
it's essentially um this is the best way
to describe it it's like a gory slasher
comedy but funneled through the
sensibilities of john waters you know
what i mean now john waters is actually
friends with joshua grinnell and john
waters actually was a producer on the
film as well so that will kind of give
you like um an idea of the kind of tone
that this movie has uh you know if slash
or gory comedy like gory slasher comedy
like with a john waters sensibility
doesn't make you want to watch it i
don't know what's the matter with you
like i don't know what else i could say
to like get you to watch it it kind of
has that same a little bit like
homegrown and like real campy vibe that
something like john waters movie like
cereal mom or something like that might
have so if you're into serial mom you'd
probably really like this as well now
natasha is it lyon or lion i'm not
really sure how you pronounce her last
name uh i recognized her immediately
from slums in beverly hills and uh the
movie but i'm a cheerleader uh this
movie actually predates her being uh you
know because i know she won a lot of
awards for being in like russian doll
and orange is the new black and stuff
like that but this was kind of like
before that so she's kind of the main
star of the movie now she stars as this
woman named deborah tennis who is a very
very unstable young woman let's call it
that who will essentially do anything to
keep her father's beloved san francisco
revival movie house the victoria theater
up and running the victoria theater is
actually a real place in san francisco i
don't know if they shot it there or if
they just like recreated it for the
movie but it is like a real iconic like
theater that they're referencing so at
the beginning of the movie there's a
prologue set in 1984.
which a young deborah who is dressed as
dorothy from the wizard of oz she's
singing very awkwardly like a little
introductory song because i guess like
her family's theater is doing a
screening of the wizhevas so she kind of
like went up there to sing and her dad
is like accompanying her on the piano
and he's always telling her you're going
to be a big star one debate you're going
to be in the movies and all this like
that but like she said she's not she's
not homely little girl or nothing like
that but she's like very very shy and
awkward clearly so her dad like believes
in her but then she her mom tammy who is
just the worst she's like super super
cruel and in this sequence in the
flashback sequence she's actually
dressed as the wicked witch of the west
uh you know which it's about keenan very
on the nose uh she starts mocking the
poor kid like at pretty much every turn
like you're never gonna mount anything
blah blah so during the song
the kids and parents in the audience
were kind of like snickering at this
awkward little girl like singing this
song and deborah gets so nervous that
she essentially like pees herself right
and then she like there's a puddle on
the by her feet and then she gets
electrocuted like when she touches the
mic stand you know what i mean uh she
does survive this but
she's obviously uh not gonna be right
after that okay so the movie then jumps
ahead to the present day and debra who
now i'm assuming as a result of the
electrocution now has kind of like a
very kicky like bride of frankenstein
like streak of white at her hair which i
thought was a nice touch she's actually
working as a librarian and she's also
doing like pulling night shift over
she's trying to keep her dad's uh
deteriorating movie theater open so
she's basically it's just like a one
screener it's really really small and so
she shows screenings of like old horror
and exploitation flicks like you know
blood feast or you know blood orgy the
she-devils stuff like that like you know
ted v mickles hg lewis all that kind of
stuff so she shows that kind of stuff
to sort of like a not very big just like
this little handful of kind of hardcore
horror hounds that come there every
weekend to see them
so when we find her in the present like
her dad has just died
and she's really upset about it
obviously and tammy her [ __ ] mother
just wants to sell this old dump to
developers so they can like put a bed
bathing beyond there or something like
that
but debra i mean she very much took to
heart her dad's whole thing was like the
show must go on she wants to keep the
dream alive uh but tammy's just kind of
like you know you and your dad you're
both [ __ ] losers and you're never
gonna amount to anything so it's like
why don't you just give it up you know
she's like i said she's she's a real
[ __ ] now one of the aforementioned
horror hounds who never misses a friday
at the victoria theater is this kid
named steven and he's like a high school
student
and the funny thing about that he
actually in his room at home he has a
poster of you know elvira mistress of
the dark above his bed and his mom in
the movie is played by elvira herself
cassandra peterson although she's
absolutely not being she's being total
mom she's like total serious mom she's
not being like funny or like boob jokes
or nothing like that so it's like really
really fun i don't know i find that
really i found that really amusing like
in a really like nice bit of casting but
uh yeah so they make like a couple like
winks and homages to that but i thought
that was like really really funny uh
steven it should also be mentioned
develops kind of something of a crush on
debra as the movie goes on even though
she's you know clearly quite a bit older
than him and that ends up causing some
complications when he figures out what
she eventually gets up to so one night
deborah's mom tammy sachets into the
theater
and basically tries to force deborah to
sign the contract that will allow her to
sell because i guess the theater was
left to her and deborah like jointly so
she needs deborah's signature on it and
deborah's like absolutely not i want to
keep it alive for dad and all this other
stuff so basically like tammy is just
like burns her on the hand like on the
popcorn maker or whatever and she's like
okay fine i'll finally do it but then
she you know her mom just keeps like
berating her and braiding her and
finally she's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
she just like stabs her to death
she stabs her to death with a pen it's a
it's pretty rad right in the lobby of
the victoria while the patrons inside
are waiting for the main feature to
start
now the elderly projectionist whose name
is mr twiggs now he's worked at the
theater for decades and he actually
stepped out on an errand to like get
some medicine or something so a frantic
debra like rushes up to the projection
booth she wants to get blood fees
started before the theater
the theatergoers get a more restless
than they already are
unfortunately while she's kind of like
pressing around trying to get the movie
to start she accidentally screens the
security camera footage of the murder
she just committed like her killing her
mom with the pen and so she's like oh
[ __ ] i'm so busted
but then mr twigs comes back and finds
tammy's body like laying there all
bloody in the lobby and he decides he's
gonna step up and help deborah out
because he always thought tammy was a
complete twan and she totally had it
coming
so he goes to the front of the theater
and tells the audience you guys have
just witnessed the very first short
horror film made by deborah tennis
herself and that from now on like before
every like main feature every friday
night there are going to be original
horror shorts she's going to keep making
them and you know because it's like a
big hit because nobody thinks it's real
everybody just kind of thinks it's like
a movie so he kind of like takes
advantage of that to also like cover up
the murder so he then helps her out
again by cleaning up the crime scene and
like sticks tammy's corpse up in the
crumbling attic of the old building to
sort of rot away quietly he's like this
is up way too high nobody will smell it
it'll be fine so from then on debra and
her right-hand man mr twiggs they start
making essentially short snuff films uh
bumping off annoying theater guests and
you know other people that just kind of
like cross their path that they think
they can do away with without getting in
trouble and they start screening the
films as fiction every friday night to
essentially like a steadily growing
audience and they start to
sort of law deborah as the hottest new
cult filmmaker in the bay area
so debra
she gets more and more unhinged as the
movie goes on uh starting to fancy
herself something of an auteur i guess
she starts dressing like a 40s silver
screen diva like acting super over the
top like some joan crawford kind of [ __ ]
that kind of stuff insisting her name
now be pronounced deborah denise like
instead of different that is it's like
super funny so her films are all based
around classic literature and they all
have like really great titles like the
maiming of the shrew and a tale of two
severed titties uh the scarlet leper
goran piece i mean seriously watch the
entire end credits because they'll put
like they made like posters for all the
movie because some of the movies they
show them like making them in the movie
but some of the ones they didn't mention
them and stuff so they but they made
like posters for them anyway and they
show them like during the end credits
and they're [ __ ] great like just the
titles of them are like super funny like
i said they're all
like they're all sort of like puns on
either classic literature titles or you
know titles of old movies but like with
a horror flair too like i know why the
caged girl screams like stuff like that
so there's like a bunch of them they're
super funny so then like as her ambition
starts to expand she also ends up
recruiting a couple of psychos to kind
of like serve as her film crew slash
murder squad and one of these is this
scuzzy criminal guy played by uh noah
sagan segan uh who was also in starry
eyes he was in tales of halloween he was
in knives out he was in scare packages
you'll recognize him immediately if
you're into horror and also a pair of
homicidal twins
just released from an asylum who like
killed their parents when they were
children and now they're grown up and
they're letting them out uh and they're
played by jade and nikita ramsay movie
also uh has a small role for the famous
john waters regular mink stole who i
believe was in every single one of john
waters movies if i'm not mistaken uh she
stars as deborah's kind of busy body
co-worker at the library and she gets to
star in one of the snuff films and also
has an appearance by uh director joshua
grinnell playing his you know drag alter
ego peaches christ there's also a little
bit of a subplot about stephen
who's
because he's real into like the macabre
and he's really into horror movies and
he's always like drawing like [ __ ] up
like pictures and stuff
so it makes him a prime suspect when
people around town start disappearing
now i will say i particularly liked kind
of the satire here because even though
this is set in the present day it does
have kind of like a little bit of a
throwback vibe still
and i kind of vividly remember being
called into the high school guidance
counselor's office more than once
because one of my pearl clutching
teachers
thought there was something wrong with
me like after she saw me reading like a
clyde barker novel or something like
that before the class you know and that
was like late 1980s so that was the [ __ ]
that horror fans had to put up with like
back in the day i don't know if that's
still the case but back then it was like
if you liked horror at all especially if
you were a girl they were just kind of
like something's the matter with you
but yeah as i mentioned uh all about
evil is just
buckets and buckets of fun it's super
fun uh made with just such obvious
affection for trashy old horror movies
and it's just kind of like filled to the
brim with like homages like little winks
to it like not just horror movies but
just like old classic uh horror movies
like classic literature there's all kind
of like funny i mean you don't need to
know all of the references to enjoy the
movie because it's still fun anyway but
i think that like richens the experience
um
it's really really gory uh it's real
really over the top i mean uh deborah in
particular i just love like as the movie
goes on she starts wearing like the
beret and the fur like
with the cigarette like acting all
[ __ ] it's great it's just it's so
funny she just like chews the scenery up
she's just like completely demented it's
really awesome so like i said if you
ever wanted to see kind of like what a
mashup of maybe like a john waters movie
in a h.g lewis movie would be uh this is
probably as close as you're gonna get so
if you're into horror comedies if you're
into trash cinema if you're into like
camp like camp horror camp cinema
anything like that then you definitely
should see this it's a really lot of fun
and uh i liked it a lot like i said it's
on shutter at the moment and also
several films has a blu-ray might be
streaming elsewhere not really sure but
yeah i would really recommend this one
if you like horror comedies and if you
like really gory like over-the-top kind
of stuff so yeah that will do it for
this flickers of fear and i will see you
guys on the next one bye